you
thank you everybody welcome so I am a
professor of psychology and cognitive
science and let me start out by telling
you a little bit about why I do what I
do when you go to school most of you at
your age you don't get much choice in
what you're going to study you have to
study English and physics and all that
stuff that they that they make you sit
through when you go to college you get a
bit more choice and so you have some
some options about what you should study
and here I think is the best piece of
advice I have ever seen by anyone about
what what you should spend your time
studying when you get when you get the
choice in any field find the strangest
and most fascinating thing and then
explore it this is actually advice from
a physicist about what to do in physics
but I think it applies across all of
science so if we were to follow this
advice and we were to say okay what is
the strangest and most fascinating thing
in the entire world
I think that the answer is clear and it
is us now that doesn't actually narrow
it down very much you could study us in
the context of poetry or archeology or
biology and so we can keep going we can
say okay what is the strangest and most
fascinating part of us and again I think
the answer is clear the strangest and
most fascinating part of us is not our
elbows it is not our knees it is our
brains and so I am a cognitive scientist
and what cognitive scientists study is
basically the study of how the strangest
and most fascinating thing in the world
works we study how the mind works we
study things like perception language
reasoning attention morality
intelligence all of these things that
make us who we are that give us our
human nature my background is actually
kind of interesting in cognitive science
I started out in a different area of
science I was a computer scientist and I
was interested in what we call
artificial intelligence the study of how
we can get computers
to do human-like things I eventually
became much more interested in non
artificial intelligence that is to say
in in human intelligence and so now I
study how the mind works with a focus in
particular on the first thing listed up
here perception now what we have learned
in cognitive science if we've learned
anything is something that we sometimes
call instinct blindness now what does
this mean
instinct blindness is the idea that we
take for granted we underestimate so
much of the magic of who and what we are
because the brain makes so much of what
we do seem so obvious and so natural and
nowhere is this more true than in the
study of seeing seeing is something that
you have done today
thousands of times since you got up but
if you ask yourself you have no idea how
it works if I ask you for example how do
you recognize somebody's face the only
honest answer you can give is that you
have no idea it seems to occur beneath
the surface but what we've learned as
scientists is several of the most
seemingly magical inspiring things that
we do like seeing the world in the first
place are exactly those sorts of things
that are the hardest challenges that the
brain faces and so there's an incredible
amount of interesting magic going on
underneath the surface and what we're
going to talk about today is how some of
that how some of that magic works and
I'll just comment by way of motivating
our topic of seeing today here's a
here's a brain this is where it all
happens all of your thinking and loving
it all happens in this couple pounds of
of meat and you might be interested to
learn that almost half of the brain is
devoted just to helping us see the world
in the first place by the way this is
this is a brain that has been soaking in
formaldehyde for a while for the
of you who aren't grossed out if you
want to see what a brain actually looks
like when it's when it's fresh here you
go
so we're going to be talking about what
about half of this half of this organ in
our bodies is devoted to now as I said
we typically take for granted perception
when I when I go to parties and I tell
people that I study visual perception
people usually say oh what's what's the
big deal they'll say oh so you like
study the eye and I have to step back a
little bit and say well not really in
fact I know surprisingly little about
how the eye itself works but I think
this is a this is an important question
because it tells us that we typically
think of seeing as if it's just a simple
matter like like maybe what a camera
does but it turns out that what we see
is not just a function is not just a
result of the light that enters the eyes
but it's a result of what happens in the
brain on the basis of that light that
enters in the eyes and we can make this
point to start out with pretty quickly
already by focusing on something some
simple sort of aspect of what we see so
one of the things that we see is color
we see the world in color and you might
wonder why why do we see the world in
color well presumably there's some
there's something out there in the world
we would actually call it the different
wavelengths of absorption and reflection
of different objects but we might say
just there's something out there in the
world that differs about different
objects and how the light scatters off
different objects and that's what causes
us to see color but it turns out that
the the answer of how we see color is is
more interesting than that so here's a
little demonstration for you this is
kind of a strange washed out image and
there's a black dot right in the middle
of it so I'd like to ask you to stare at
that black dot and don't move your eyes
keep your eyes fixated right in that
black dot and I'm going to turn the
lights off here for just a second
and in just a second I am going to
advance the slide to the next the next
slide here and there's going to be
another picture on the screen and that
picture is going to have a black dot at
the same point here and what I'd like
you to do is - as soon as I go on to the
next slide I want you to keep staring at
that black dot for one second don't we
in other words when the next slide comes
up don't move your eyes keep your eyes
fixated right there and keep staring at
the dot for one second and you can just
notice what the image seems like and
after one second I want you to close
your eyes you with me all right keep
staring at that black dot okay in just a
second now I'm going to advance the
slide stare at it for one second and
close your eyes but don't move your eyes
keep them at the black dot here we go
okay close your eyes you might be
surprised to learn that that second
image that I showed you was completely
in black and white there was no color
there whatsoever now this time I'll let
you appreciate that let's do this again
keep staring at that black dot keep
staring at that black dot and this time
why don't you do this
oh don't stare at that black dot there
we go keep staring at this black dot
again for about maybe 15-20 seconds and
again I'm gonna advance to the next
slide this time why don't you keep
staring at the black dot for just like
half a second or one second and then
move your eyes to anywhere else in the
image okay so here we go keep your eyes
on the black dot
all right so already we can start to see
that there's something there's something
kind of interesting going on here you
want to do it one more time
yeah okay all right here we go this only
works if you keep your eyes really
really still focus right at that Center
right at that center spot all right and
here we go
so already we can see that what's going
on when we see the world even when it
comes to seeing a simple feature like
color is a little more interesting than
we might have expected the reason you
saw color in this image is not because
there's color in the image it's a black
and white image but somehow what we did
first was sort of fooling the brain into
seeing that there's color and so what
this shows us is that the perception of
the world even the perception of
something like how the color of objects
is not just a is not just caused by the
light that enters the eyes it's caused
by your brain what's actually going on
in this situation is that we have these
colors that are affecting certain cells
in your brain
certain types of photoreceptors that
respond to different wavelengths of
light and they sort of push against each
other and so when you spend a long time
looking at one color like this blue here
in the same part of your visual field
it'll suddenly turn red it wants to see
red for a second and that's what's going
on here we'll come back to this idea in
a little bit so the magic of perception
is not the light that enters the eyes
it's what your brain does with that
light and we'll talk a little bit today
about how this works and we'll talk
about two questions the first question
is what do we see and the second
question is how do we see let's start
with this first one what do we see well
this is a question that I think everyone
has a very intuitive answer to what do
we see we see whatever's right in front
of our eyes the answer as we have
discovered through doing some extremely
surprising scientific experiments the
answer tells us that that that idea that
what we see is right in front whatever
is right in front of our eyes is not
true what we see is much more surprising
than that so the big probably the
biggest problem that the brain faces
when trying to see the world is that
there's way too much information going
on out there to process at any one time
as a result the brain has to focus on
only a
all bit of the light that enters the
eyes at any given moment and we're kind
of familiar with this in other context
who knows who this is who's that Waldo
okay everyone has seen Where's Waldo
there's Waldo and then in a typical
Where's Waldo cartoon you have to go
find Waldo and it's pretty hard now
Waldo I'm telling you is right in front
of your eyes right now but you don't see
Waldo because even though Waldo is right
in front of your eyes you are not
directing your attention you're not
paying attention to Waldo there's also
something really sort of mean going on
in this image
what does Waldo look like Waldo is like
red he's got a lot of red he's got these
stripes well here there's all sorts of
red in the image there's all sorts of
stripes in the image and so you could
stare at this for many minutes before
you see does anyone does anyone see
Waldo yet Oh some okay some people are
Waldo experts here here we are there's
Waldo right in the middle behind those
two behind those two women now the fact
that Waldo has red stripes and that
there's a lot of red and that there's a
lot of stripes in this image is what
makes Waldo hard to find and we can see
this in some even more simple displays
so here's a here we can do this
experiment right here I'd like to have
everybody raise your hand just raise
your arm up and I'm gonna give you a
task here to find Waldo but Waldo is
pretty boring here Waldo is just the the
red circle so as soon I'm gonna go I'm
going to show you an image and as soon
as you see the red circle I want you to
put your hand down on your desk so that
everyone can hear you let's practice one
two three all right all right all right
and we're gonna be able to hear how long
it takes people to find this extremely
boring Waldo all right so I want
everyone as soon as you can find the the
pink the pink or the red circle here put
your hand down all right here we go one
two three
now that was boring okay that was pretty
simple let's try again find the find the
red or the pink disc here as soon as you
find it
on everyone put your hand down again
like that so everyone can hear here we
go alright it just kind of jumps out at
you there's a lot of objects on the
screen but did you feel like you had to
like search around to try to find it
no it just sort of jumped out at you why
might that be why might that be in this
image what what makes oh it's okay you
don't have to do it mm what what makes
that pink disc do you suppose easy to
find in this image yeah what do you
think it's different than all the other
ones right unlike the Waldo case it's
totally different it's the only pink one
in the display or it's the only circle
in the display let's try again
this time to find the find the yellow
disc everyone put your hand up and as
soon as you find the yellow disc put
your hand down so we can hear you here
we go
that sounded a little different let's
try again
this is even more complicated you're
looking for a little bar that is yellow
and tilted to the left like that as soon
as you find it put your hand down
all right what's going on here well this
is in this situation what we just heard
here from the front row is no longer
true there's no single feature that this
particular Waldo shares that makes it
unique in the display right it's not the
only yellow thing it's not the only left
hilted thing or in this image
it wasn't the only circle it wasn't the
only yellow thing this is what makes
Waldo hard to find when the thing that
you're trying to attend to isn't going
to jump out of the display you now
attention we're all familiar with
attention all of you who are in school
have probably had people tell you to pay
attention attention we have learned has
three components it has selectivity
selectivity is the idea that even though
the light that enters your eyes is all
the same you can pay attention you can
select some information but not others
it has a capacity limitation which is
just to say there's a limit on how good
you can be at doing this and there's a
sense of effort involved and let's try
to take these and try to feel them so
here's another little here's another
little task for you and this is the kind
of thing we do in our laboratory we
bring people into our laboratory and we
have them do experiments like this to
try to figure out how attention works so
here are a bunch of little disks on the
screen little white circles and in just
a second one of them is gonna blink oh
we have a question here yeah what is
what need to say that one more time one
of them is blue one of them is blue yes
that is completely right that little
thing in the middle is blue I'm gonna
ask you to just completely ignore that
that one is that one is not going to be
interesting as you'll see the other the
other circles are going to be a little
more interesting here in just a second
one of the other white circles is going
to blink and that one is your target and
even though you're gonna have them all
in front of you they're all going to be
entering they're all going to be
entering your visual system I want you
to try to keep track of just the one
that blinks
so at the end of the motion it'll blink
again and you have to tell me if you
managed to track it the entire time you
with me all right it's like a little
simple extremely boring video game let's
try it
so there's your target try to keep track
of it
how'd you do everyone get it alright
that's way too easy
we already concede the sense of effort
involved notice how the room got quiet
here everyone had to had to do what had
to pay attention but let's try to see if
we can get a sense of the capacity
limitation and feel the effort a little
bit more that was obviously too easy for
all of you let's try to keep track of to
notice that this becomes a little harder
because now you can't just follow it
around with your eyes alright let's try
Oh congratulations now still I saw some
of you kind of cheating a little bit I
saw some people sort of going like this
yeah you could only really keep your
eyes pointed at one but you've got two
fingers anyone have three hands no okay
unless you want to bring your foot up
and try to let's keep going it seems
like you guys are pretty good at this
try to keep try to try to select try to
try to keep your attention focused on
just three of these objects
alright you guys are pretty good here we
go for now you're starting to feel the
effort involved in attention you're
starting to feel the sense of capacity
limitation alright if you're doing it
we'll keep going by
I think we can hear from the giggles we
could hear from the giggles and the fact
that strikingly fewer people raise their
hands in victory this is getting to be
around the capacity limit of the human
visual system we haven't we have
machinery in our brains that lets us
keep track of 1 2 3 4 once you get to 5
pretty hard for those couple who raised
your hands this is just for you
okay we've got some experts here here's
an interesting little factoid for you
most people find tracking keeping track
keeping your attention focused on six
objects at the same time to be very
difficult but there has been a report
that uh NBA basketball players NHL
hockey players are really quite good at
this they find it quite easy now why are
we talking about attention well remember
does anyone remember way back from like
five minutes ago what is the question
we're currently trying to ask what is
the question what do we see and we said
we typically think that what we see is
whatever is right in front of our eyes
but it turns out that's not true because
there's just too much information coming
in to the eyes at any given moment the
real answer that we've learned from
doing this science is far more
surprising what we see is only what
we're attending to at any given moment
now we can see this in some surprising
ways we can see this by looking at what
we do and we don't notice based on what
we're attending to so here is a simple
example this is another little game we
can play in the game is that I'm gonna
ask you to look at this image and it's
just a simple photograph of these two
people having having their lunch there
and I'm gonna show you a picture and
then I'm gonna change it and I'm going
to show you another picture okay and
between the change there's gonna be a
little flash of a gray screen and I'm
just going to go back and forth and back
and forth and you have to find what is
changing okay and to make this clear so
everyone can see how we're doing what
isn't everyone raise your hand and as
soon as you can tell what is changing in
these pictures put your hand down you
don't have to do it loud we can just
keep keep track of people's people's
hands here you ready all right let's try
this let's see if this works well that
wasn't very good let's try that again
mm nope let's try that one more time
there we go okay so everyone put your
hand up and keep your hand up until you
can see what's changing now
there's a big change between these two
pictures and it's right in front of your
eyes not only is it right in front of
your eyes but you're trying to see it
and the change has occurred 20 times 30
times already right in front of your
eyes if your hand is still up take a
look at the railing
okay everyone can see this now the
railing is going up and down and now
that you see it it seems so obvious what
was it obvious when you were first
trying to find it except for a couple of
you it wasn't now why couldn't you see
this thing happening right in front of
your eyes well that there are two things
going on here that make it that make it
a little tricky the first thing that's
going on is that the first thing that's
going on is you were not attending to
that information what was everyone
looking at the food the faces the people
no one was at paying attention to the
railing and as a result you completely
failed to see what was going on there
the other thing that's going on that
makes this work is also kind of
interesting why are we putting that
flash of a gray screen between each of
the two images well the reason is that
if we didn't have that gray screen in
between there your attention would
automatically jump to the railing as
soon as it starts moving because that
movement would grab your attention but
we're not letting it grab your attention
because we're making sure that
everything changes at the same time by
changing from that gray screen do you
want
now the degree is just a way of changing
what's going on so that at every moment
when the railing changes all of the
pixels in that image are changing at the
at the same time exactly we use it as an
intermediate step so that's kind of
surprising that you can't see that
change do you want to try it something
like that again yeah okay let's try it
one more let's try this one all right so
same exact thing here's the first image
it's going to cycle back and forth
between two images hands up and keep
your hands up until you can tell what's
changing
let me just say that the thing that's
changing in this picture it's kind of
important
the reason it's kind of important is
that you wouldn't want a ride on an on
an airplane that didn't have an engine
now again once you see that that engine
is coming and going it's so obvious
but it's not obvious when you first try
to look at it because even though it was
right in front of your eyes you weren't
paying attention to it all right now you
might at this point stop and say you
know that's kind of cool but these are
flickering pictures back and forth like
this one would something like this ever
occur in the real world and of course it
wouldn't but there are other situations
in the real world where you might be
blind to changes that are going on in
front of you if you're not paying
attention to them here's another
interesting example of this this one
takes a while to load and so isn't going
to change but you can just look at it at
first here's this nice city scene and if
you just look at this at these people
walking around you can try to memorize
what's going on in the image and in a
minute Allah when I when I make it
change you can then try to find what's
changing does that sound good to
everyone I just lied to you the change
already happened the change happened
while I was talking so everyone does
everyone see that that building right up
there in the left let me put that slide
up again
so what are we doing here in this case
that building is coming on to the screen
but remember I said if something comes
on suddenly your eyes will automatically
be pulled to it here we're just putting
it on gradually enough so that you don't
see it but you still might say you know
what yeah okay so that could maybe
happen more than flickering in the real
world but how often do you go around
walking around the world and things are
slowly fading on and fading off well the
one thing you might say is how would I
know if they were since you wouldn't see
it yes here's an interesting here's an
interesting experiment that was run once
upon a time the researchers did this
experiment to explore the real-world
implications of this kind of thing and
they ran this experiment on a college
campus during a day when all the
students were moving in and so there
were tons of people walking around
carrying boxes and everything and they
stopped and asked some one of the
experimenters stopped and asked someone
for directions and they did this over
and over and over and they were filming
it as they did it so you can see what
happens so here's this guy his name is
Leon and he stopped this nice fellow and
it's just asking him for directions to
the music building and this other guy
comes over to help and he's pointing
where the music building is and
something kind of rude is about to
happen these people who are carrying a
door walk right between those two people
did everyone see what happened there the
person the person that they ended up
talking to is a completely different
person and what they did in this
experiment is then they asked people did
you notice anything odd about the person
you were just talking to and a striking
number of people completely failed to
notice that the person they were talking
to completely changed so watch out I'll
show you I'll show you one other one
other example of this here the
researchers then move to a different
University and they actually they faced
a problem which is this new University
said you're not allowed to run that
experiment because that experiment when
we run experiments as scientists we have
to tell people carefully what the
experiment might involve they have to
sign a form that says I agree to
participate in the experiment and so the
researchers thought well how could we do
this how can we make them sign a form if
we're gonna do this and here's what they
did so there's one experimenter there's
another experimenter completely
different person kinda hard to see in
this photo but they're actually wearing
actually wearing different colored
shirts and everything and they set up in
a university to run an experiment and
people walking by could sign up to be in
a study and as one of them was walking
up they would stand there and so here
comes this person and we have the hidden
plant camera here and she's like hi I'll
be in the experiment and the person says
okay can you sign this form saying
you'll be in the experiment he says okay
let me file this form just a second
and the person who stood up and
completed the discussion with her and
told her to go down to the room at the
end of the hall was a completely
different person and again even in this
even in this situation people completely
fail to notice that the person talking
to them was a completely different
person so the lesson here by the way at
this point I should hold on just a
second no I'm the same person so the
lesson here what do we see the answer is
we don't see whatever's right in front
of our eyes we see whatever is right in
front of our eyes that we pay attention
to if we're not paying attention to
something we're not necessarily going to
see it by the way this is the kind of
science that interacts with the real
world in interesting ways kids how many
of you have seen your mom or dad or some
other person who's not your mom and dad
talk on their cell phone while they were
driving in the car hmm
beyond being against the law if you look
at car accidents for example and you
look at what causes car accidents
well sometimes like someone stops really
quickly or something like that but the
most common cause of really bad car
accidents is you know some motorcycle is
in front of you or there's another car
or there's a little girl crossing the
street and why do you hit the person
because you didn't see them that's
that's what happens in in accidents
people say well why did you hit the
person that was running across the road
I didn't see them and you say well wait
a min you didn't see them you were
looking somewhere else you were you were
looking down at your feet or at the
radio they say no I was looking right
out the window and I just didn't see
them well the thing is when you're
driving your car especially if you're
talking on your cell phone you make you
pay extra careful extra care too for
example looking in your blind spot
looking in those regions that you know
are gonna be hard to see but here's
something you don't do you don't spend
extra time and effort to try to see
whatever is right in front of you why
because you assume that you'll see
whatever's right in front of your eyes
but it turns out that we don't so
attention controls what we see
and don't talk on your cell phone while
you're driving let's turn to another
question we've talked about what do we
see let's talk about the question of how
do we see well we started out by saying
that one of the most important things
about perception is that there's too
much information coming into the eyes to
process the second most important thing
about perception is that there's not
enough information coming in to the eyes
what do we mean by this there's not
enough information it turns out for the
brain to figure out the way that the
world is outside that would have
produced the pattern of light that hits
our eyes we scientists sometimes call
this an inverse problem inverse just
means the opposite and what happens is
out there in the world there could be
all sorts of objects and those objects
light scatters off those objects and
ends up hitting the eye but the problem
is there are always multiple ways that
the world could be that would cause
exactly the same pattern of light to hit
the eyes and so if what we're trying to
do when we see the world is try to
figure out the way the world is
technically speaking mathematically
speaking that is impossible whenever you
have a little line in front of you for
example suppose you see some little line
well what is that it could be something
very small that's very close to you or
it could be something big that's farther
away from you that might cast exactly
the same pattern of light on your eyes
furthermore it doesn't even if you see a
little line in front of you you don't
even know the orientation of it it could
be sort of bent it could be oriented in
some different way so vision in this
sense is impossible and we can see this
in a couple of different ways here's a
here's a simple image for example this
is not a computer rendered image this is
just an image of an actual object and
can you recognize what that object is
little toy ambulance or something like
that right and how do you see that well
because it's got all this information
that tells you what it is it's got all
this color and light that it's your eyes
let's pick let's pick it up and take a
look at it
does everyone see what's really going on
there it is a little toy ambulance but
it's not it's not what you think it is
it's a sort of hollow cut out of an
ambulance okay how many of you can even
see it that way now probably probably a
couple of you but it's pretty hard you
want to see that again
all right let's pick that up again
why is it so hard to see what's going on
at first well because the light that
hits your eyes from an actual little toy
ambulance and the light that hits your
eyes from this sort of deceptively
constructed hollow concave toy ambulance
is exactly the same here's another nice
illustration of this sometimes you see
these examples of a sidewalk art so here
is a painting that someone did on a
sidewalk and you can see looking at it
that it's completely insane right you
might not be able to see what it is yet
but there's something going on here and
then this is actually this is actually a
woman's leg it's her foot and it's drawn
all the way over here and if you look at
it if you look at that piece of Arts on
the sidewalk from most perspectives it
looks completely crazy like that
but if you stand in one certain spot
this is what it looks like and now
suddenly it looks like a really good
piece of art it sort of jumps out in 3d
and the reason is that if there were an
actual woman taking a bath in the middle
of the sidewalk the who was sticking her
leg up in three dimensions that would
cast exactly the same pattern of light
on your eyes as what's actually going on
so the brain has to try to figure this
out you might wonder by the way if this
is impossible you might wonder wouldn't
wouldn't motion help because after all
if you're trying to figure out what this
really is well you could just sort of
start walking around to the side and
pretty soon you'll see that this is
actually what's going on so to help
figure out whether motion helps did
everyone get one of these little things
when they walked in these little
champagne wires can you raise your hand
if you don't have one of these okay so
maybe if we've got any extras here
people could but we're running out okay
so you will have to share this is a this
is a little what this is is actually the
top thing that holds a cork on a bottle
of champagne so for you we in the
psychology department in the perception
and cognition lab just drank 150 bottles
of champagne last night so that we could
try this so I hope you
appreciate this I'd like to try
something here so what I'd like you to
do is to so first of all note that you
can hold this out and there's kind of
there's a little circle and there's a
big circle right everyone see that
there's sort of a little circle at the
top and there's a big circle and to
start out with I would like you to hold
it so that the little circle is closer
to you than the big circle and hold it
out at arm's length and close your for
most of you we're gonna close your
non-dominant eye which if you don't know
what that means close your left eye and
make the two circles overlap a little
bit so make the little circle in the big
circle overlap and just with one eye
closed note what that looks like maybe
put the put the little circle to the
left of the big circle with the little
circle closer to you so the two circles
overlap and you can just kind of see
what that looks like okay now what I
want you to do is turn it around so that
the little circle is now farther away
from you okay still hold it out at arm's
length still keep one eye closed keep
your left eye closed and have the two
circles overlap try to make it look the
same way it did before so that the left
the little circle is a little bit to the
left of the big circle but they overlap
and you can note that it makes it look
the same way but there's something else
you can do here that's a little bit more
exciting so here's what I want you to do
I want you to hold it out with one eye
closed with the little circle farther
away from you overlapping the big circle
and I want you to just stare at it until
you can see it as if the little circle
is closer to you how many of you can do
that alright so when you get to that
point when even though it's farther away
from you you can see it as if it's
closer to you I want you to start ever
so slowly twisting it back and forth
you can hear when this starts to work
for people because they say oh how many
of you notice something a little bit
strange happening alright so so a guy in
the sweater here why don't you why don't
you put it what what is happening with
what is happening when you start turning
it you turn it left but it moves right
you turn it right it moves left how many
of you are able to to see this happen
okay if you can't see this happen here
is a gift for you you can take this home
and for the rest of the day keep playing
with this for those of you for whom this
little demonstration is working you
might ask why that seems completely
crazy when you move it left actually if
you're paying really close attention you
might notice that you're moving it left
and it's moving to the right twice as
fast as you're actually moving it why on
earth would this be for those of you for
whom this isn't working I've lost you
for the rest of the lecture you're gonna
be busy doing this until we get to the
3d glasses the reason this works the
reason this is so surprising is that it
turns out that the pattern of light that
hits your eyes from having the little
circle close to you and moving to the
left is exactly the same pattern of
light that hits your eyes when the
little circle is farther away from you
and moving in the opposite direction
twice as fast and so the brain has to
somehow figure out what's actually going
on in the world and solve this
impossible problem by the way does
anyone know why did I ask you to close
one eye why do you think I asked you to
close one eye yeah
so you say that really loud
okay good there if you have two eyes
open you have extra information that you
can use to try to figure out whether the
little circle is closer or farther from
you and I want you to hold that thought
because we're going to come back to how
that works in just a second all right
vision is impossible and what we see is
a function not just of it's a function
not just to the light that hits the eyes
but what the brain interprets about
what's going on that's not just true of
seeing in three dimensions it's also
true of something seemingly even simpler
so here's a quick you didn't I don't
think they told you there was gonna be a
test today but here's the test what
color is that square black all right now
that seems like a pretty easy test
but even that turns out to be a kind of
surprising thing that you see that as a
black square after all let's just turn
this off for a second what color is this
screen gray or white and it looks gray
or white but now hold on these machines
up here are the projectors that that
shine these slides onto the screen our
machines that shine light onto a screen
and if the screen is white you can't
shine light onto a white screen and make
it any darker all you can do is make it
like them so this thing that you see as
black is the same thing that you're
seeing as white right here it turns out
that even the perception of how light or
dark something is it isn't just a matter
of the number of photons that hit your
eye it's a matter of what your brain
decides is going on on the basis of that
here's here's a nice way to see this
here's a little computer rendered image
and it's pretty straightforward there's
this sort of green cylinder on this
checkerboard now more tests more test
questions some of these squares look
light and some of them look dark and so
if I say for example how bright what
kind of square is this one white
what kind of square is this one what so
one of them is a light gray one of them
is a dark gray
and you might wonder why why do you see
that as like gray and dark gray well
presumably because it is like gray and
dark red hold that hold the question for
just a second
and you might be surprised to find out
that those two squares are exactly the
same
it's not true that one is light and one
is dark they're exactly the same now
it's kind of hard to see that so let me
help you so focus on the square and the
square when I do this normally people
sometimes don't believe me so let's uh
let's see if we can help you out here by
getting rid of the rest of the image
they're exactly the same I hope you
appreciate that by the way that only
took me like four hours last night in
the program to make all to do all of
that so those two squares are exactly
the same now you know that they're
exactly the same
let's bring the image back now they
don't look the same what is going on
here we'll come back to this in just a
second so how do we see the way that we
see is not just by operating like a
camera the brain it turns out does not
get enough information to to to
determine what's going on out there in
the world and so your brain basically
has to be like a detective your brain is
like Sherlock Holmes it's taking the
light that comes into the eyes and it's
trying to figure out what is going on
out there in the world now this is the
most complicated boring slide in in our
talk today and I'll try to make it a
little a little simpler how do we see
this is the answer to how we see the
brain makes heuristic assumptions about
the world and causes us to see the world
that was most likely to have produced
the light that hits our eyes all right
let's break this down a heuristic does
anyone know the term heuristic a
heuristic is like a rule but it's like a
rule of thumb it's an assumption that
you might make that your brain might
make in this case about what's going on
that doesn't always have to be true but
it's going to be true usually and it's
kind of a quick helpful way to figure
out what's going on and so the reason
for example that you see this is light
and this is dark is because of the
operation of a heuristic of a
heuristic rule it's an assumption that
your brain is making what is that
assumption well there are two types of
changes between light and dark in this
image one of them is this are these sort
of sudden changes between light and dark
but there's another thing going on here
that you may not have been sort of you
might not have noticed but your brain
definitely noticed it and that's that
this cylinder is casting a shadow
so everyone see the shadow it's kind of
a fuzzy change between light and dark so
this is a little bit lighter than there
this is a little bit lighter than there
well what your brain is trying to do
when you see light and dark is to not
count the light that's sitting there you
want to see what the world is actually
like and not just what the sort of
ambient lighting in the room is and so
your brain has a has a heuristic your
brain has a little rule and that rule
says that things that are in shadow are
actually a little bit lighter than they
would appear to me then then the light
that's going to hit the eyes and things
that are not in shadow are maybe a
little bit darker than they then things
that would be in a shadow and so this
square that looks light is inside the
shadow what about this square it's
outside the shadow your brain is being a
detective and so your brain as soon as
you see this image says you know what
I'm getting the same number of photons
from those two squares but one of them
is a little bright one of them is in a
shadow and so I think that one is
actually probably a little lighter than
the number of photons that hit my I
would suggest and so I'm just going to
amp this up and what you see is the
result you see one look lighter because
of that here's another little heuristic
assumption that's kind of surprising
this is something that wait until
Halloween time and you could do this by
yourself
so here's a little example of a mask
faces it turns out are really important
to your brain it's very important to see
other people's faces to sort of
understand what other people are
thinking how they're how they're
attending as a result
your brain likes to see faces in all
sorts of situations for example even in
situations where you might know that
there really aren't any faces as soon as
you see this you can tell what all of
these fruits and vegetables are thinking
and feeling and etc you can tell what's
going on in the image like this
sometimes you might you might encounter
the fact that your brain likes to see
faces even in places where there aren't
really any faces we seem to be we seem
to have a hair-trigger on seeing
something like faces but seeing faces is
still hard
why because well there's just not enough
information out in the world to figure
out what's going on your brain makes an
assumption and here's the assumption
that it makes the assumption is that if
it sees something that seems like a face
that object is probably convex that is
to say it sort of sticks out as opposed
to being concave now when would you ever
see a concave face when you're looking
at the inside of a hollow mask if you
look at the inside of a hollow mask it
can look a little strange let's do it
this is a this is an old school little
movie here and it's just a little
Halloween mask here we'll listen to that
we'll listen to this this is kind of
good
your brain refuses to see the inside of
a hollow mask as the inside of a mask it
wants you to see it as a face that's
sticking out because it has this
heuristic assumption wired into it the
other part of that complicated answer to
how we see is that we see what the brain
thinks is most likely to have produced
the light that hits our eyes let's try
to see a simple example of this and then
we'll have one more demonstration to end
with so let's start just simply here if
you see these two little lines you see
it as an angle but of course it doesn't
have to really be an angle it could be
two completely unconnected lines that
just happen to line up right it could be
like this and you're just looking at
them so that they're not actually
touching but they just happen to be
ending at the same point but think now
suppose these two lines are matchsticks
and suppose you threw two matchsticks up
in the air how likely is it going to be
that they would end up perfectly
touching very unlikely how likely is it
going to be that they would not end up
touching perfectly with their points
together very likely so basically what
that means is if they're not the same
thing
then the fact that they would be
connected at that line is just a
coincidence but your brain refuses to
accept the possibility that what's going
on there is a coincidence and so it
forces you to see that as two lines that
are connected let's make this a little
more complicated when you look at this
you see these four patmans do I still
know what a pac-man is packing okay
thank goodness all right
I'm not old yet here we have four pacman
that are sort of arranged just in a
willy-nilly order here are four pac-man
but do you see just four pacman there or
do you see something else what do you
see you see a white square that is not
true that is an illusion that your brain
is painting for you there is no white
square there here's another example
here are three pack men and three little
triangles three little black triangles
but what do you see you see a big white
triangle that white triangle is not
there it is an invention of your brain
why is your brain inventing a white
triangle well because there are two
possibilities one possibility is that
these are really three black circles and
some connected lines and that there's a
white triangle sitting on top of them
the other possibility is what's really
going on here that there is no white
triangle but there are sort of three
pack men in these lines that just happen
to be perfectly aligned but remember
what we said if they just happen to be
perfectly aligned and there is no
triangle there that would be a
coincidence your brain refuses to accept
the possibility of a coincidence and so
it forces you to see that white triangle
in fact how many of you see a little bit
of a difference between this shade of
white and that shade of white it's not
there that is an illusion that your
brain is painting for you to help you
see that white triangle that it has
decided was there
it sort of paints it for you in a
slightly different a slightly different
color all right I'm gonna skip that and
I'm gonna talk about how this works
coming back to this idea of seeing in
three dimensions so this is the last
thing we're going to do today and we're
going to talk about one of the biggest
challenges of perception which is one of
the challenges we started with how do
you see in three dimensions the world in
front of you is three dimensional
but the light-sensitive part of your eye
it turns out is only two dimensional so
you just get like a drawing or a picture
of what's going out in the world and the
brain has to somehow infer three
dimensions now does everyone remember
when we were holding this out I asked
you to close one eye now I'm gonna tell
you why I had you close one eye one of
the tricks one of the many different
tricks that the brain uses to help us
see in three dimensions is something
called stereo vision
in stereo vision capitalizes on the fact
the interesting fact that we don't just
have one eye we have two eyes and our
two eyes are pretty close and so what
you see out of your left eye and what
you see out of your right eye is
basically the same thing but there are
some subtle differences and it turns out
those subtle differences are really
important so let's do this for a second
hold up your finger in front of your
nose and and put it really close to your
nose and now close your left eye and now
close your right eye and telling us ask
yourself how far is your finger moving
say on the screen here on the background
okay now do the same thing but hold your
finger out as far as you can and now
close your laptop and now close your
right eye and ask yourself how far is
your finger moving when you do that on
the background is it moving more or less
when your finger is farther away less
does everyone see that
if you move your finger really close to
you your finger is like moving across
the whole room if you move your finger
away I'm trying to do it's only moving a
little bit it has to do something tricky
it has to show your right eye and your
left eye something a little different so
by the way there's another way you can
do this do you guys still ever see these
things these uh these uh stereo scopes
or view masters I guess you can still
buy one that has Harry Potter on it
these days alright so here we have
something no no no no don't don't don't
do to take those glasses off here we
have some simple shapes on a screen in
and there are blue lines and there are
red lines and in each case there are
some blue lines and red lines now in a
second what you're gonna do is you're
gonna look at this with your special
glasses and one of the lenses of the
glasses is red and one of the glasses is
blue so basically this is just a really
cheap way to help you see the left one I
will see the red and one I will see the
blue because these lenses will filter it
out now if you take the glasses off for
a second let's look for example and
let's let's look at this let's look at
this image right here
and let's ask ourselves
take this take this vertex right here
this little point is the blue and the
red really close to each other or are
they really different from each other
they're really close right that blue
point in that red point are almost
exactly the same what about down here is
that more or less of a difference more
and what about right here a lot more so
if your brain is a good detective your
brain should be able just like when you
were holding your finger out in front of
you like this you should be able to put
your glasses on and see this in three
dimensions and it hop for how many of
you is does this work here this is so if
this jumps out for you in 3d you should
be able to see this vertex is closer to
you this vertex is farther from you in
this vertex in the middle is this
working for people all right this is how
you see in three dimensions this is how
a 3d movie works but this is what your
brain is doing all the time whenever
your eyes are open to let you see in
three dimensions and you can do some
pretty cool things with even simple 3d
glasses like this for example take off
the glasses for a second here here is
just a simple picture of an eye but it's
been constructed carefully so that your
eyes would see slightly different things
put the glasses on looks a little better
suddenly doesn't it looks like it's in
looks like it's in three dimensions it
turns out that other scientists even use
this technique for example so here for
example is a microscope picture of the
surface of a piece of paper and it turns
out that if you look close enough even
the surface of the piece of paper has
all sorts of canyons and valleys and
ridges and mountains and it's hard to
see that though but if you make an image
that has the left and right eyes
slightly different how many of you can
see this as if it's like popping out in
depth all right so there you go your
brain is like a detective oh one more
thing if your brain is trying to put the
left eye on the right eye together and
is being a detective and is doing all
this like subtle math about how far
apart is this how far apart is this
between your left eye and your right
you might wonder what is your brain
gonna do if the left eye and the right
eye see something that's not just a
little bit different but see something
that's totally different
let's find out every one I put on your
glasses
I'm going to show you a blue image and a
red image but they're going to be
completely different and you can just
tell me what what do you see
close your left eye now close your right
eye now keep both of your eyes open at
the same time
here is an example of your brain not
being able to make up its mind some
someone someone raise your hand and tell
me what did you see when your eyes were
open what did you see and did you see
them both at the same time how many of
you sometimes saw only one of them and
then what happened did it stay always
like that one it suddenly switches Moop
it suddenly switches here's a case where
your brain is trying to put these two
images together to figure out what's
going on in depth and it just fails and
so you see what's in front of one eye
loom and then you see what's in front of
the other eye
and your brain can't make up its mind
all right so what we've seen here is
what we see in the first place is not
just what's in front of our eyes but
it's something much more surprising than
that it's only what we attend to and how
do we see how we see is the brain has to
make all sorts of detective-like
inferences to figure out what's going on
in the world in the first place and I'll
just end with with one sort of extra
demonstration here sometimes the the
inference that your brain can make is
that an object out there that's that has
light that's hitting your eyes isn't
even there in the first place sometimes
what your brain decides is that it's not
there so let me tell you one other
interesting fact about your eyes I said
I didn't know much about the eyes but
I'll tell you one thing about the eyes
the light-sensitive part of your eyes
the part of your eyes that accepts the
light and transduces that into energy
which goes into your brain is not on the
front of your eyeball it's in the very
back of your eyeball that's kind of a
weird engineering solution that means
there's all sorts of stuff in between
the world and the light-sensitive part
of your eye what we call the retina the
question is why don't you see that stuff
there are blood vessels for example that
run along the surface of your eyeball
why don't you see those blood vessels
why don't you see the shadows from the
blood vessels the reason is they don't
move relative to what's going on in the
rest
the visual field and as a result your
brain decides that it's not there and it
erases it from view and we can see
another example of this so everyone this
is the last this will be the last slide
here everyone take a look at this
without your 3d glasses please
and there are there are three things in
this image there's a bunch of blue
crosses there's these two little white
circles and then there's this bright
yellow disk okay now what I'd like you
to do in just a second I'm going to make
these blue crosses move and I would like
you to keep your eyes just like we did
this at the beginning with the the
example of color I would like you to
keep your eyes fixed on those white
circles and do not move them it's going
to be hard to do this but you need to
try to really not move your eyes and
keep them aimed right at those two white
circles and then I want you to notice
what we're gonna do with the yellow disk
all right let's try this keep your eyes
fixed right in the middle of those two
white circles and the blue crosses are
moving and what are we doing with the
yellow disk
we're occasionally taking it away and
bringing it back except that we're not
it's it's disappearing not from the
screen it's disappearing from your mind
and we can we can have you have you see
this but let's do this again but this
time this time wait until it disappears
keep your eyes fixed right at those two
little white circles wait until it
disappears and as soon as it disappears
just move your eyes a little bit to
anywhere else in the image and see what
happens to the yellow dot
okay it disappears but then what happens
as soon as you move your eyes it jumps
back it jumps back and why is that
because your brain remember what we see
is not just what's in front of our eyes
what we see is what the brain in its
detective-like way figures decides is in
front of us
your brain is deciding that it's not
there your brain is basically saying you
know what what's going on here here's a
little spot that's not playing along
with the rest of the visual field and
that's staying perfectly fixed relative
to my eye your brain decides that it's
not there and it erases it from your
visual awareness until you move your eye
and then your brain says oops I guess
that's out there in the in the world in
the first place because it's moving now
relative to my eye and it it jumps back
into your awareness so what we see is a
much more fascinating scientific
complicated matter than what we would
typically take completely for granted so
for the rest of today as you walk around
seeing things try not to take it for
granted so much and and be aware that
what we see is not just a simple
function of your eye acting like a
camera but it's your brain doing some
amazing things thank you everybody